[music] openly preparations were underway for another punitive operation in the Donbass for an invasion of our historical lands, including Crimea in Kyiv, they announced the possible acquisition of nuclear weapons, the NATO bloc began active military development of the territories adjacent to us, thus systematically created threats that were absolutely unacceptable to us, and directly at our borders, Russia gave a preemptive rebuff to aggression, it was forced to make a timely and only right decision, the decision of a sovereign strong independent country, you are fighting for our people in the Donbass [music] all of a sudden [music] dear comrades, today the militia of Donbass, together with the fighters of the Russian army, are fighting on their own land, you are fighting for the Motherland for its future so that no one forgets the lessons of World War II so that there is no place in the world for executioners and Nazis [music] [music] [music] Russia has always advocated the creation of a system of equal and indivisible security of a system that
is necessary for the
entire world community
in December last year, we proposed to
conclude a security guarantee treaty
Russia called on the West to
close dialogue to find reasonable
compromise solutions to take into account
each other's interests
all in vain NATO countries did not want to hear us,
which means that in
fact they had absolutely  other plans and we
saw it